Oh my God, we had the best time ever.
Oh my God.
I mean, I, it's like,
I was reading some of the questions
and going through it with our amazing producer,
and I was like, "Oh my God.
And then this, and then there was this.
And then there was that."
And then I came across the story that you remembered.
Okay, so one of them,-
I think I know what you're talking...
We were, well, one of them was
we were on a private jet, which is always so memorable.
That was, I'd never been on a private jet before.
And I was, I didn't know how it worked,
like who's flying it.
And then we got on, we were all,
I just was trying to behave,
'cause I felt like I didn't belong there.
And then by the end we were trying to throw Cheetos
into each other's mouths.
Guess we got really comfortable,
really quick.
I think we did.
We got really comfy.
Yeah, 'cause I was 19 and washed up
and trying to come back.
I was not Private Jenning it anywhere.
I was-
But you were so, I don't know.
You were so adorable and sweet and so glamorous in this way.
And we'd, I remember Whoopi and I would come get you
in the golf cart.
Yes!
And You'd be like,
"Hey" and you'd be like, "What'd you do this weekend?"
I'd be like, "I got a new hat"
and I'd be like, "What'd you do?"
And you went, "I got a new husband."
And I was like,
(audience laughs)
"Hey, what, what did..."
It's true.
I remember that so well.
And Whoopi, of course, was like, "What?"
Yeah.
Like, "You did what
over the weekend?"
I was like, "I got married."
You know,
sometimes it's a weekend.
You have to have an activity.
(audience laughs)
It was in a bar.
It was an accident.
At 3AM.
Things happen in bars.
We've all been in bars.
We called a dial-a-preacher.
Do they have those?
Yeah, back then.
So, okay.
You are in a play right now called "How I Learned To Drive".
Yeah.
Shockingly cool, full circle fact.
You are doing it with the incredible actor, David Morris.
There's history there.
Yeah.
We did the play 25, I can't add suddenly,
25 years ago.
Are you a Pisces?
Yeah.
I mean, you did this play.
Yeah, 'cause I was 30.
So I'm 57, so...
And you look so hot.
You walked out, I was like, "Oh my God!"
Oh my God, thanks.
(audience applauds and cheers)
What fountain?
What, where did you sell your soul?
What fountain are you drinking out of?
I think I decided a while ago
that it's really tempting to kind of like
mess with yourself, but I decided I wanted,
I'd rather look like a young old lady
than an old young lady, you know?
I don't know.
I've never heard it put that way.
I know, I don't know that I have either, but...
And I love that.
Yeah.
There's something to also being able to say,
I'm 57 years old
and I've lived every single one of those years
and I'm not trying to look 52 or 49 or, you know,
I have to tell you-
That's just what I am.
How healthy that is too.
I've,
(audience applauds and cheers)
It's so healthy.
It really is.
I can't think of a better film
that I would love to pick your brain about,
that I think is such an extraordinary celebration of women
and such a timeless classic,
is "Fried Green Tomatoes",
because that is both perspectives.
(audience applauds)
That is the younger
and the older,
and boy, in that film, does it just,
I've got chills talking about it.
That is a film that really celebrates wisdom.
Aging, life, maturity.
Yeah.
I mean, I think growing up is not overrated.
I like it.
I love it.
There's something,
when I, I was really worried when I turned 50
and then I turned 50 and I couldn't stop saying it.
I was like, "I'm 50, I'm 50, I'm 50."
Did you have a good time making that movie?
'Cause boy, did we have the best time watching it.
Yeah, I felt really lucky to be a part of it.
I hadn't made many movies
and I just felt I couldn't believe
that they gave me the part,
and working with those other actresses,
Kathy Bates and Jessica Tandy and Mary Stewart,
it was just, it felt like, "Oh, here you go.
here's this enormous gift."
And I just felt really lucky.
And we worked, you know, Mary Stewart works really hard
and we worked really hard and there were,
there was a strange incident
that where I had to jump into a pool,
lake, actually.
And they told me ahead of time
there are no water moccasins.
They'd scanned the area
but they had not scanned for leeches.
(audience gasps)
Wait, did you get leeches?
(audience groans)
One, I got leech.
Yeah.
Where?
So, I said-
On what part of your body?
Let's just say, somewhere in this region.
(audience groans)
Yeah, not good.
So, and I was wearing a slip.
Like undercarriage?
Mm.
Netherlands?
Mm, yeah, down below.
(audience laughs)
I was wearing a slip and I had to jump into the,
to this little pond, which had no snakes.
But leeches.
But leaches
I'd rather a leech than a snake, I think.
Yeah. I'm okay with snakes,
Wild ones?
Not water moccasins,
but then they said, "Oh, can we get somebody?"
I guess there was like a whole,
because it was the south
and they were just kind of used to it.
A grip came over with a big flame.
Yep.
Yeah.
And just burned it right off,
and then I did another take and I was like-
Back on the horse.
Back in the water.
Back on the leech.
Back in the water,
(audience applauds)
I mean, what are the chances I'd get one again?
Very small.
(bright theme music)